so Dr Phil uh what's going on here okay
what we've got here is a metal pipe with
a whole lot of holes in it we're pumping
gas through it and we've lit it up as
you can see so we have like a whole lot
of uh buns and burners all in a row
whole bunch of little Flames burning gas
and um this is all very pretty but what
does it have to do with science just you
wait I've got a speaker on the end here
whoa so there you go you're pumping a
sound through the pipe now is that right
that's right it's quite an annoying
sound Phil let me change
[Music]
it okay a few changes happening yeah so
there's these areas where the flame is
higher and other areas where the flame
is not as high what's causing
that well it kind of looks like a wave
doesn't it yeah it definitely does look
like a wave but I mean what is it
showing us why is it got these high
points and low points well sound is a
wave when I speak my vocal cords vibrate
air which sends a wave to your eardrum
vibrates your eardrum and that's how you
detect sound okay so how is this sound
wave changing the height of these Flames
well the wave is actually areas of high
pressure and low pressure in air so
there's actually a sort of compression
traveling through and that's what we can
see is the pression in the pipe here
there's area where there's high pressure
areas where there's low pressure and
that results the higher pressure is
obviously pushing the gas out uh faster
and so we're getting these higher Flames
that's right in a simplistic way pretty
complex situation but what about if we
change
it so you made it a higher pitch
now and I noticed that these Peaks are
sort of getting closer together that's
right yeah so we've actually changed the
wave by having a different frequency
we've made a short shorter wavelength
we've changed the sound wave changed the
sound wave that's we've made a higher
pitch so that's a higher frequency yep
it's vibrating faster and to get all
those vibrations in it has to do it in a
shorter space in a shorter wavelength
shorter wavelength okay but uh this is
all very interesting but you know it's
killing my ears so what are we going to
do let's go for something a bit more
musical shall we all right let's try a
fairly simple tone so I'll I'll just
[Music]
whistle
so that's uh not bad let's have a let's
have listen to someone singing you know
anyone who can sing a bit I I don't know
anyone who can really sing oh jeez all
right it's
just that you and me are made of these
at hey do you know any
Mozart I don't
I'm I'm sure I'm sure you know a bit of
mod maybe you heard it in the womb here
go have a have a try of this okay I'll
just warm the orchestra up ready you
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
than
[Music]
[Applause]
very
good